right he's cut my taxes by one percent
thanks rishi at the same time he's
raised national insurance by two and a
half percent which i don't pay and which
rishi doesn't pay at least on his income
from his wealth because we get our money
from our wealth so he's he's cutting
taxes on on the super rich and raising
taxes on working people you know it's
it's it's give with one hand and take
with the other look there are some small
tax reductions announced yesterday
we estimate that there are about a third
of the tax increases that he's announced
up till now so the average family is
going to be paying one and a half
thousand pounds more in tax than they
were before israel came in as chancellor
so you know let's not beat about the
bush here rishi sonak has raised taxes
on ordinary working people whilst
presiding over the biggest ever
increasing wealth of millionaires and
billionaires so yeah i mean it's
political theater right he gives very
loudly and he takes very quietly but
he's taking more than he's giving the
only group to which he's given more than
he's taken are the super rich who's seen
a 21
single year increase in wealth so if
richardson himself who's worth 200
million pounds if his wealth has
increased in line with the average
millionaire in this country he would
have made 42 million pounds in the first
year of kobe and it's not just him
that's all of the super rich in the
country the average billionaire made 630
million pounds you've got it in the
first year of kobe it's crazy this is
not a case of
everybody's hurting but the poor hurting
the most this is a case of the poor and
ordinary hurting and the rich have never
ever ever made more money so i know i
keep banging on about it but i'm going
to keep banging on about it because the
only way we save ordinary families like
the people listening to this now
is by getting that money back from the
super rich so we have to do something i
would encourage anybody listening to
come and support me and call information
to raise taxes on the rich the super
rich or millionaires like me or
millionaires like rishi himself
so that we can support the ordinary
hard-working families of this country
instead of raising their taxes
when i was a trader we didn't watch the
statements because the statements are
not about economics the statements are
about political theater if some risky
sonic has raised taxes significantly on
ordinary working people okay two and a
half percent extra on national insurance
which is everybody's wage and excludes
the incomes of the super rich by the way
he's significantly increased tax on
ordinary people he's done that quietly
and now he's giving a few pounds back
very very loudly listen it's not enough
it's not nearly enough there's not a
single family in this country for whom
the small handouts given yesterday will
even nearly make up for the massive
increase of cost of living we're talking
about thousands of pounds
extra cost of living
for every family in this country and in
many many cases in millions of cases
that would be thousands of pounds which
they simply don't have i think it's
important for people to realize we are
talking about people will lose their
homes over this people will not be able
to pay the rent to pay the mortgage
people will become homeless
it's very very serious situation and
then you know if we can take it one step
further if you're taking two three
thousand pounds out of the disposable
income of every family well that's their
entire disposable income so they can't
go to the pub they can't go to the
cinema they can't go on holiday they
can't go to the theater they can't go to
restaurants so it's going to destroy the
economy of this country look we made
this mistake before in 2008. if you deal
with a crisis in such a way that you
impoverish the vast majority of people
and make the rich super super rich all
you're going to do is see a massive
increase in house prices a massive
increase in stock prices and the economy
will be in a slump for 20 years you know
i'm probably getting too passionate
about it but this is really really
serious this is really really serious
and something has to be done
you